joining us here courtesy of snickers and
from the green bay packers one of our
favorite guests we have not spoken to
all year long his team now happens to be
because the rams over the cardinals the
top seed in the nfc going into the final
four weeks of the regular season one of
the best of the best joining us on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line on the
rich eisen show devonte adams how you
doing devante
i'm doing fantastic how about you
richard i'm doing great thank you just
terrific uh to to chat with you it's
been it's been too long
so
uh you watched last night you root for
the rams in a situation like that does
that happen for you oh yeah oh yeah
i'm real i mean obviously um you know i
gotta i got a lot of love for both teams
and respect for both teams but um you
know if any time where we can get a
little help i don't i don't ask for too
much but you know anytime we get a
little help every now and then i'll take
it for sure especially since that that
win you know uh it kind of mimicked in a
way the win that your team had in
arizona because of covid knockin uh
players out you were not in that game
what was that game like for you devonte
to watch that game in arizona earlier
this season
for you uh it was terrible man i'm not
gonna lie to you it was my first time
watching a packers game um since my last
year in college man my first time
watching it live on tv so
um you know i missed some games early in
my career but i never was in a position
where i had to be at home i was always
you know traveling and on the road with
my guys so
it was bad it was it was tough and i was
also struggling with covert at that
point um you know had a headache and
then watching the game wasn't helping
that so
um weird experience but it was it was
definitely good to get out of there with
a dove either way well now it's all good
in the hood for sure for you uh in green
bay now that you're you're sitting there
at ten and three atop the conference
what what what works why why does it
work so well do you think in green bay i
know that's a very general question but
you know
we see so much that goes on
dysfunctional in in the nfl and we see
changes that happen at coaches we see so
much that happens but it just seems to
work so well what does work so well in
green bay for you well i think that
what we do well and what we did
particularly well on sunday night was is
the in-game adjustments i feel like a
lot of teams you know you're not this
this league is about match-ups so you're
not always going to come out and
dominate the way that you you draw it up
you know obviously when you're scripting
in practice a lot of times you script
for the best look or you know the you
know you dial up a choice right you
obviously want man coverage so you're
gonna do that and then in the game you
may not get man coverage so how are you
gonna adjust and how you're gonna be
able to um you know
make make changes on the flyer going at
halftime like what we did make halftime
adjustments and come out to where you
can come um dial it up and get the body
of playmakers and i feel like we do a
great job of that um we don't always
play a perfect full game and we're still
in search of that type of game um but at
this point we just really we found out
how to win and um you know obviously i
we've shot ourselves in the foot a few
times early on this year didn't start
off great versus saints and
got that our system and played some
pretty good football since then so now
it's just putting it together for four
quarters and then uh you know we'll be
really really tough team to stop at that
point so how does that work can you take
me in the locker room halftime
adjustments it's lefleur it's what
rogers you who's who's sitting around
talking about this sort of stuff when
you got 15 minutes to figure this thing
out yeah well it feels like it's five
minutes honestly you don't feel like you
got 15 minutes in there you got
the defense on one side of the locker
room and offense on one side some chairs
old lines sitting down
and um you know the coaches are on the
white board and they're they're drawing
up plays i don't even know the whatever
they're drawing up honestly i don't even
more more the the constructive stuff for
us is going on when i'm having
conversations face to face with matter
face to face with aaron about how i was
being played in the first half and they
asked me you know different route
adjustments that i'd like based off
being backside alone um or if i'm in a
slot you know we just do a really good
job communicating and that's a credit to
matt and his staff are
you know giving me the floor and
trusting me and trusting my my knowledge
of the game and um and what i'm seeing
out there because you know i can give
great feedback based off of leverages
and you know different ways that i can
beat some of these doubles and i think
that's been the biggest adjustment this
year is that i'm not really getting a
lot of single coverage so
the communication has to be at a premium
and we've been doing a really good job
with that the best receiver at his
position is voted by his peers and the
nfl 100 davonte adams of the green bay
packers here on the rich eisen show i'm
gonna throw a couple of things your way
that uh that that uh
i've observed at least to me from where
i'm sitting watching games and watching
your games and you tell me if i'm on to
something or not it seems that your
coach matt lafleur is saying it with his
chest a little bit more often i see him
a lot more demonstrative on the sideline
i see him
am i you're laughing am i right or am i
wrong with that
hey man i love it first of all the
delivery of that statement was was uh
was premiere by you thank you sir thank
you
i stuck the landing i did okay thank you
appreciate it
that was just even better though because
i mean i definitely see that i think as
you continue to have more more and more
success as a player coach scout whatever
it is
it builds your confidence so um and you
get to know you build better
relationships with your guys because you
go to go through things throughout the
season so i think just based off of how
battle tested we are and you know
different different ups and downs that
we've had just just really throughout
each game you know some of the stuff
that we got to put up with and still go
out there and get doves that gives the
coaching staff and the players a lot of
confidence and i think that's why he's
kind of walking around
not walking around any type of way but
definitely like you said he's staying
with his chest a little bit more and you
know it's just our confidence is really
high as a team definitely not a cocky
state whatsoever um because we got a lot
of humble players and humble coaches in
that locker room but i think everybody
really understands what's in front of us
and we've been really consistent as a
team for the past two years so um this
third year now being um you know near
the the final quarter of the season i
think it's saying a lot who we are that
we're you know back in the driver's seat
um potentially putting ourselves in a
position to have a buy uh first round
again so obviously we still got four
games to go out there and handle
business and and it's not it's not done
until it's done um and you know it's
it's fun that this nfc race is so tight
like this too because it keeps us on our
job it makes us tap in and lock in each
and every week and um you know so that's
definitely how we're going to have to be
if we want to go into super bowl this
year and the other thing devonte adams
that i'm i'm i'm thinking i'm seeing i
kind of feel it that whatever that was
in the off season aaron rodgers is
through it i don't know over it might be
too much of a supposition because i
don't know what goes on in his temples
but it's just like it just he seems
happy and comfortable and that
you know that that everything is working
and that he's you know he's here an mvp
chance from the fans and you guys are
winning and he's got you
he got cobb who i hope to see back but
do you get that sense that he's he's
kind of there to stay
devonte well i mean i hope so man hope
so um this is definitely been the the
same i've got the same type of vibe as
what you just said there he's been um
definitely good spirits and i think that
just we're kind of the same type of guy
in the sense that
you know certain things that go on in
the off season and there's a time and a
place for certain things you know
figuring out the business aspect of it
whether it's contract situations or you
know whatever aaron had going on with
his situation and then once that time
goes by and it's time to play ball and
just lock in and go do what we love
we have a good
we have i feel like we compartmentalized
that really well and uh that's something
that he does extremely well obviously
playing the type of ball he's playing
right now and um yeah just got to lock
in on the moment lock in on what you're
doing actively that's how you produce
the best results what about you is your
future tied to his at green bay do you
think devante
thank you potentially but like i said
i'm the same kind of mindset as what i
said about him my all my success has
been kind of um
attributed to just being locked in in
the moment enjoying playing playing ball
with my teammates going in and producing
and at a high level and trying to focus
on being the best
every week the best me and just the best
period so that's that's more of my
mindset and then once uh once we wrap
this thing up hopefully with a ring um
we can figure out where everything is
headed with that um but during the
season i'm definitely not um you know at
this point
played a lot of ball we're just gonna
finish it out and like i said try to get
this ring and then see what happens up
there i got to be honest i i mean you
get a ring you guys get a ring i mean
why why
why wouldn't you just want to run it
back you know what i mean like why
wouldn't no i know there's a lot of
dollars in sensitivity
i agree i agree there's a lot of a lot
of truth to that um but but as you know
um you know better than most it's a
business so there's a lot of stuff that
goes into it um other than just saying
hey i want to be back and there's a lot
of things that go into it so at the end
of the day we
we gotta lock in on this part first and
then we'll head into that and try to try
to map out and see if we can you know
keep the family together but um yeah we
got a few games to win before we even
start thinking about all of that all
right let's uh before i let you go talk
about what uh you're doing with snickers
we showed the video before is that
really your artwork devonte uh
i would be lying if i said it i i could
like i was saying earlier i think i
could produce something similar um
you know if you expected a lot less uh
but but definitely that that wasn't my
work um the acting is me though so
or something like that later on
but yes snickers is they they launched
um a new uh campaign called uh the
rookie mistake of the year which they're
ultimately going to give a fan who has
the ultimate rookie mistake of the year
um at the end of the season they're
going to award them with um two tickets
to super bowl 56 so that's um a really
cool opportunity they'll be able to go
to um
snickers rookiemistake.com to submit
their video and um yeah that's kind of
what i was doing in that picture just
painting
trying to turn some masterpieces uh out
of some rookie mistakes that people
submitted over time so cool cool deal
and and it was really really fun going
out there filming that thing well your
next painting uh should be my rookie
mistake uh devonta adams um you know and
you're you're you're born in redwood
city so you you know all about redding
california uh so does aaron who's from
you know chico so i i was up in redding
california i was a sportscaster of note
i would like to say um and uh but
despite my enjoying my time there i was
looking to get a job in a larger market
and i left my resume on the printer and
my news director found it
so wow well i i kid you not that seems
like something that would have 100
percent been uh a painting i could have
reproduced
yeah
if you can kind of paint a picture of
what that would look like i'd be happy
to get you something for your office
well uh thankfully it did not uh result
in a photograph of me having to put all
my things in a box you know and
and get out uh but that was my i
definitely did that uh i also locked my
uh equipment in the trunk of my car
uh on my first assignment uh for that
station
my god how the hell did i get how did i
get to where i am today i don't know
what i did but i did that too yeah you
were letting that letting the moment get
too big i see yeah i did i didn't have
my head on a swivel you know what i mean
i wasn't premier at that point to use
the phrase that you used with me earlier
on
so no doubt okay i hope i used that
right now you did you did
snickers rookie mistake um and go to
again snickers
rookiemistakes.com because the winner
gets two tickets to super bowl 56
perhaps to see you sir in it here you
guys talk about that stuff openly you
literally use the word super bowl you
talk about it
oh yeah i mean i think some teams may
not because you don't want to
psych out certain people but you look at
the the scope i've been in for nfc
championship games so it's not it's not
i mean it's basically super bowl the bus
is the mentality coming into it when you
when you're on the team like the green
bay packer so um certain certain teams
may try to keep that out and just do the
best that they can but we know what the
best that we can do is and that's that's
getting to the ultimate show and getting
out there
and uh getting some hard work when we
leave so that's the goal davonte adams
greatly appreciate the time really
appreciate it say hi to rashaan gary for
me will you please he's uh
he and i are in the same boat on new
year's eve rooting for our alma maters
against georgia so we're good good luck
thank you good luck with that and i will
i will definitely let uh bain gary uh
know you said hello please do that
thanks for the call appreciate it
devonta let's do this more often
appreciate it thank you yes sir devonte
adams everybody check him out
every single week
at tay85 adams on twitter check him out
fun stuff right there hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here